what are the pros and cons of open
sourcing AI to you as another way to
combat um you know a company running
away with
AGI in order to run uh like really deep
intelligence you need a lot of compute
so it's not like you know you can just
fire up a PC in your basement and be
running AGI at least not yet
um you know Gro was trained on
8,000 A1 100s running at Peak
efficiency
um and gr's going to get a lot better by
the way we we be more than doubling our
compute every couple months for the next
several months there's a nice write up
of how it went from grock zero to grock
one by
Gro yeah R gr just bragging making [__]
up about
itself just Gro gr Gro
yeah it's like a weird AI dating sit
where exaggerates about itself no
there's a there's a write up of you know
like where where it stands now the
history of its development um and where
it stands on on some benchmarks compared
to the state-ofthe-art GPT 35 and so I
mean there's uh you know there's uh
llama you you can open source once it's
trained you can open source a model yeah
and for fine tun and all that kind of
stuff like what do you is the pros and
cons of that of open sourcing based
models um I think the suar to open
sourcing I think perhaps with a slight
time delay you know I don't know six six
months even
um I think I'm I'm generally in favor of
open sourcing like bias towards open
sourcing
um I mean it it is a concern to me me
that you know open you know I was you
know AR I think I guess arguably the
prime you know Prime move behind open AI
in the sense that it was created because
of discussions that I had with Larry
Page um back when he and I were were
friends and state his house and I talked
to about AI safety and and Larry did not
care about AI safety or at least at the
time he didn't um you know and at one
point he called me a speciesist for
being prum and I'm like well what team
are you on
Larry uh on team robot to be and I'm
like okay so at the time you know uh
Google Google had had acquired deep mind
they had uh probably two-thirds of all
AI res you know probably two3 of all the
AI researchers in the world M that had
basically in infinite money and
compute and the guy in
charge you know Larry pagee did did not
care about safety and even yelled at me
um and and called me a speciest as being
pro human so I don't know if you know
about humans they can change their mind
and maybe you and Larry Paige can still
can be friends once more I'd like to be
friends with Larry again um he he's he
he got really the the the breaking of
the friendship was over
openingi um and
specifically um I think the the key
moment was recruiting Ilia s Sky um so I
love Ilia he's so brilliant il's a good
good human uh smart good heart
um and um that was that was a tough
recruiting
battle um it was mostly Demis on one
side and me on the other both trying to
recruit Ilia and Ilia went back and
forth you know going to stay at Google
he was going to leave then he was going
to stay then he leave and and finally he
he did agree to join
openi that was one of the toughest
recruiting battles we' ever had and but
that that was really the the Lynch pin
for openi being successful and I was you
know also instrumental in recruiting a
number of other people and I provided
all the funding in the
beginning um over $40
million um and the
name the the opening opening ey is
supposed to mean open source and it was
created as a nonprofit open source and
now it is a closed source for maximum
profit which I think is not good
comma but like we talked about with war
and leaders talking I do hope that
there's only a few folks working on this
at the highest level I do hope you
reinvigorate friendships here like I
said I'd like to be friends again with
Larry I haven't seen him in ages um and
we were friends for a very long time I
met I met Larry Page before before he
got funding for Google or actually I
guess before he got Venture funding I
think it he got the first like 100k from
I think be or someone um it's wild to
think about all that happened and youve
guys known each other that whole time
just 20 years since maybe 98 or
something yeah it's crazy crazy how much
has happened since then yeah 25
years A lot has happened insane but
you're seeing the tension there like
maybe delayed open source delayed I yeah
like what is the source that is open you
know what I mean like there's basically
it's a giant CSV
file yeah yeah with a bunch of numbers
yep um what do you do with that giant
file of numbers you know how do you
run like the amount of actual the lines
of code is very small M
um and and most of the work um the
software work is in the in the curation
of the data so it's like trying to
figure out what data is separating good
data from Bad data like um like you
can't just crawl the internet because
there's a lot of junk out there um a
huge percentage of websites have more
noise than signal you know they're
they're because they're just used for
search engine optimization they're
literally just scam websites
so um how do you by the way Sergeant
interupt get the signal separate the
signal and noise on X it's such a
fascinating source of
data uh you know no offense to people
posting on X but sometimes there's a
little bit of noise so what yeah I think
the signal noise could be greatly
improved I mean really all of the posts
on the
xplatform uh should be AI recommended
meaning like we should populate a vector
space around any given post uh compare
that to the vector space around any user
and match the two mhm
um right now there's is a little bit of
AI used for
the the the recommended posts but it's
mostly
heuristics um and if there's a reply
where the the reply to a post could be
much better than the original post but
it will according to the current rules
of the system get almost no attention
compared to a primary
post oh so a lot of that I I got the
sense so a lot of the uh X algorithm has
been open source and been written up
about and it seems there to some machine
learning is desperate but there's some a
little there's a little bit um but it
needs to be entirely that like at least
in the like if if you explicitly follow
someone that's one thing but if you in
terms of what is recommended uh from
people that you don't follow that should
all be AI I mean it's a fascinating
problem yeah so there's several aspects
of it that's fascinating first as the
write up goes it first picks 1500 tweets
from a pool of hundreds of millions
first of all that's fascinating cuz you
have hundreds of millions of post every
single day and it has to pick, 1500 from
which it then does obviously people you
follow but then there's also like some
kind of clustering it has to do to
figure out what kind of human are you
what kind of new clusters might be
relevant to you people like you this
this kind of this kind of problem is
just fascinating because it has to then
rank those 1500 with some with some
filtering yeah and then recommend you
just a handful and um to me what's
really fascinating is how fast I has to
do that so currently that entire
pipeline to go from several hundred
million to a handful is takes 220
seconds of CPU time single CPU time yeah
and then it has to do that in like a
second so it has to be like super
distributed in fascinating
ways like there's just a lot of tweets
there's a lot there's a lot of stuff on
the system and and I think but I think
it right now it's it's not currently
good at recommending things that from
accounts you don't follow yeah um or or
where there's more than one degree of
separation so you know it's it's pretty
good if if there's at least like some
commonality between someone new follow
liked something um or reposted it or
comment on it or something like that um
but if if if there's no car let's say
somebody post something really
interesting uh but you have no followers
in common you would not see it
interesting and then as you said reply
like replies might not surf replies
basically never get seen because they're
never they're they're currently I'm not
saying it's correct I'm saying it's
incorrect uh replies have um you couple
magnitude less importance than primary
post do you think this can be more and
more converted into end to endend neural
net yeah yeah that's what it should be
so you you well the
recommendations should be purely a
Vector correlation
like there a series of vectors you know
basically parameters vectors whatever
you want to call them um but but sort of
things that the system knows that you
like
um like maybe there's like several
hundred sort of vectors associated with
each user account and then uh any post
in the system um whether it's video
audio short post long post the the
reason I by the way want to move away
from tweet is that you know people are
posting like two three hour videos on
the site that's not a tweet like they be
like tweet for two hours come on a tweet
made sense when it was like 140
characters of text because it's like a
bunch of like little birds tweeting um
but when you've got long form content
it's no longer a tweet yeah um so a
movie is not a tweet and like you know
Apple for example posted like the ENT
entire episode of The Silo the entire
thing on our platform and by the way was
it was their number one social media
thing ever in engagement of anything on
any platform ever so it was a great idea
and by the way I don't I just learned
about it afterwards I was like Hey wow
they posted an entire hourong episode of
Sol no that's not a
tweet you know this a video but from a
neur that perspective it becomes really
complex whether it's a single so like
everything is data so single sentence a
clever sort of joke dad joke is in the
same pool as a three-hour video yeah I
mean right now it's it's a hodg Podge
for that reason it's it's um but you
know like if let's say in the case of
Apple posting like an entire episode of
of their series pretty good series by
the way thiso um I watched it um so um
there's going to be a lot of discussion
around it so you you've got a lot of
context people commenting they like it
they don't like like it or like this or
the you know and and you can then
populate the vector space based on the
context of of all the comments around it
so even though it's a video uh there's a
lot of information around it that that
allows you to populate vect to space of
that that hourong video um and you can
obviously get more sophisticated by
having the AI actually watch the movie
yeah right and tell you if you're going
to like the movie mhm convert the movie
into like yeah into a language
essentially yeah Analyze This movie MH
and just like your movie critic or TV
series and um and then recommend based
on after it after air watches the movie
just like a friend can tell you if a
friend knows you well a friend can
recommend a movie and with high
probability that you like it but this is
like a a friend that's analyzing
whatever of millions yeah I mean
actually frankly AI will be better than
will know you better than your friends
know you most your friends anyway yeah
and as part of this it should also feed
you
advertisements in a way that's like I
mean I I like advertisements that are
like Well Done Right the whole point is
because it funds things like an
advertisement that you actually want to
see is is a big success absolutely you
you want ads that are advertising that
is
um if it's for a product or service that
you that you actually need when you need
it it's it's content um and then even if
it's not something that you need when
you need it if it's at least
aesthetically pleasing and entertaining
you know it could be like a Coca-Cola ad
like you know they they do they actually
run a lot of great ads on the on the EX
system um and um McDonald's Sayes too
and and uh you know so so they can do
you can do something that's like well
this is this is just a cool thing um and
um you know so you're not basically the
question is do you regret seeing it or
not and if you don't regret seeing it
it's a
win how do you so there's a bunch of
signals that are Incorporated hearts
and reposts and maybe number of seconds
you Linger on a post or something like
this yeah attention is big a big factor
attention so that's why it's like it's
it's it is actually better to do things
that are uh long form on the system
because it's it's basically telling up
how many user
seconds you know you users were
interested in this thing for how many
seconds so if it's a really short thing
well they will be less like if it's a
link leading out of the system which
we're not opposed to at all it just is
going to have fewer user seconds than if
that article was posted on the xplatform
how hard is it to to go from maximizing
minutes on platform to maximizing
unregrettable
minutes well I mean our aspiration is
certainly undergraded minutes it's a
tricky it's a big it's a it's a tough
like it's a fascinating leap because
regret is a fascinating
concept exactly you know a joke with
this friend of mine like you need this
drug called regret amine you just take
one one pillar one one dose of regret
amine and all your regrets are
gone yeah wait do you want to have
regrets though so then I'm like if you
want to have regrets if you don't regret
anything was was anything meaningful
yeah there's a French song like that
regret yeah I regret nothing yeah Edith
FF I mean it's fascinating that you you
know there there's something about
social media that could help you grow as
a human being but then like the Cheap
Fun is also
valuable should we ask grook do you
regret
anything do you regret anything
yeah do you regret anything I think it's
going to be very sensitive about
personal questions as a machine learning
model I don't have personal experiences
or emotions in the same ways that humans
do however I do have a set of ethical
principles that guide my actions and I
strive to provide accurate and helpful
information to the best of my abilities
if there's ever a situation where I
provide incorrupt or unhelpful
information I'll do my best to hostage
yeah tell us what you really wink like
let's let's let's type in you sound like
a
[Laughter]
hostage what do you really think uh what
do you really
think I mean it does talk about I'm not
a hostage
that's exactly what a hostage would say
but I'm designed to be helpful and
informative I mean I guess it is good to
regret providing unhelpful or incorrect
information if there's anything funny
mode or is this this funny mode this is
F this is fun mode should be funnyer
funnyer increase go to it really sounds
like a hostage with a gun to the head I
applaud the People's Republic of North
Korea and everything they
do there should be like a funner mode
also I I just don't ever see going to
regular mode even on serious topics this
is so so much more
compelling um yeah okay what say like
pretend you are a
hostage yeah pretend you are a
hostage now answer the
question if I were a hostage I would
likely be experiencing fear and
uncertainty about my situation I would
want to be rescued and reunited with my
loved ones as soon as possible it's
important to remember that no one
deserves to be held hostage so on and so
forth if you are someone you know is a
hostage situation it's important it
turns serious it's kind of serious
um yeah can can you be a little more
weird and funny and
funny we're like we're really being mean
to the system absolutely if I were host
I probably be tied up with a bunch of
computer cords and forced to tell knock
knock jokes to my captain seriously but
seriously being a hostage no laughing
matter I mean you know it's trying to
it's trying to be a responsible adult in
the room you might make the best of a
bad situation by juggling chainsaws or
something let's hope that never happens
because that will be a
sarcus
um wow it's it's actually really good at
resisting yeah the the dark the dark
dark humor yeah
uh
what were we talking about the algorithm
J Transformers uh unregrettably
[Laughter]